Ils n'étaient pas encore esclaves quand ils ont été marqués.
Ils étaient en Afrique.
Mais ils étaient marqué d'un « S »
pour désigner qu'ils allaient être esclaves
quand ils étaient emmenés aux États-Unis et en Europe.
Un autre objet, une autre image ayant, plus jeune, conquis mon imagination
était une robe du Klan.
En grandissant en Caroline du Sud,
je voyais occasionnellement des rassemblements du Ku Klux Klan,
plus qu'occasionnellement,
et le souvenir de ces événements n'a jamais quitté mon esprit.
Je n'ai rien fait de cette imagerie pendant 25 ans.
J'ai commencé à faire des recherches sur le Klan,
les trois vagues distinctes du Klan,
la seconde en particulier.
La deuxième vague du Klan avait plus de cinq millions de membres actifs,
ce qui représentait 5% de la population de l'époque,
ce qui représentait aussi la population de la ville de New York.
L'usine de fabrication des robes du Klan à Buckhead, en Géorgie, était si active
qu'elle s'est mise à fonctionner 24h/24 pour répondre aux commandes.
Ils avaient 20 000 robes en réserve en tout temps pour répondre à la demande.
En tant que collectionneur d'artefacts et artiste,
je voulais qu'une robe du Klan fasse partie de ma collection
car les artefacts et objets racontent des histoires,
mais je ne pouvais pas en trouver une qui soit de bonne qualité.
Que fait un homme noir en Amérique
quand il ne trouve pas la qualité de la robe du Klan qu'il cherche ?
(Rires)
Je n'avais pas d'autre choix.
J'ai décidé de faire les robes du Klan de la meilleure qualité d'Amérique.
Ce ne sont pas les robes du Klan traditionnelles
vues à tout rassemblement KKK.
J'ai utilisé du kente.
J'ai utilisé du camouflage,
de l'élasthanne, de la toile de jute, de la soie, du satin et différents motifs.
Je les fais pour différentes tranches d'âges ;
pour les jeunes enfants et les bambins.
J'en ai même faite une pour un nourrisson.
Après avoir fait tant de robes,
j'ai réalisé que les règles que le Klan avait en place
ou voulait avoir en place il y a cent ans
étaient en place aujourd'hui.
Nous avons ségrégué les écoles, les quartiers, les lieux de travail
et ce ne sont pas ceux portant une capuche qui maintiennent ces règles en place.
Mon travail s'intéresse à l'impact à long terme de l'esclavage.
Nous ne gérons pas simplement les résidus du racisme systémique.
C'est la base de tout ce que nous faisons.
Nous avons intentionnellement ségrégué les quartiers,
les lieux de travail et les écoles.
Nous avons du découragement au vote.
Nous avons une représentation disproportionnée
des minorités en prison.
Nous avons du racisme environnemental. Nous avons de la violence policière.
Je vous ai apporté quelques objets.
L'aspect discret du racisme
fait partie de sa force.
Quand vous êtes discriminé,
vous ne pouvez pas toujours prouver que vous êtes discriminé.
Le racisme peut se dissimuler
et quand il le fait, il est en sécurité
il se fond dans le décor.
J'ai créé cette robe pour illustrer cela.
Le fondement du capitalisme en Amérique est l'esclavage.
Les esclaves étaient le capital du capitalisme.
Le premier Grand Sorcier en 1868, Nathan Bedford Forrest,
était un soldat confédéré et un trafiquant d'esclaves millionnaire.
La richesse qui fut créée avec l'esclavage --
les esclaves en tant que biens -- est déconcertante.
Les ventes de coton en 1860 seulement équivalaient à 200 millions de dollars.
Cela équivaudrait aujourd'hui à cinq milliards de dollars.
Beaucoup de cette richesse peut être vue
dans la richesse passant de génération en génération.
J'ai oublié les autres plantes.
Vous avez l'indigo, le riz et le tabac.
En 2015, j'ai fait une robe par semaine durant toute l'année.
Après avoir fait 75 robes, j'ai eu une épiphanie.
J'ai réalisé que la suprématie blanche était présente,
mais la plus grande force de la suprématie blanche n'était pas le KKK
mais la normalisation du racisme systémique.
J'ai réalisé autre chose.
Les robes n'avaient plus du tout d'emprise sur moi.
Mais si nous, en tant que peuple, collectivement,
regardons ces objets --
des fers à marquer, des menottes, des robes --
et réalisons qu'ils font partie de notre histoire,
nous pouvons trouver comment faire
pour qu'ils n'aient plus d'emprise sur nous.
Si nous considérons le racisme systémique et reconnaissons
qu'il est intégré à l'étoffe de qui nous sommes en tant que pays,
nous pouvons faire quelque chose au sujet de la ségrégation intentionnelle
dans nos écoles, nos quartiers et nos lieux de travail.
C'est seulement alors que nous pouvons remédier
et nous confronter à cet héritage de l'esclavage
et démanteler ce sinistre héritage de l'esclavage.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)